>> THEY
PRODUCED AT A GOOD RATE.
>> HE FEELS VERY COMFORTABLE IN
THE  1.
IS CORE POWER-PLAY GOAL IN THE
GAME.
THE MID-CHARLOTTE WIN 11-1.
FOUR POINTS LASTLY ENTASIS.
ALL OF TH DEFLECTS AND STAYS MA
BATTLES OVER THE YEAR.  WITH
ONLY FIVE OF THE NIGHT AND  SAV.
THE PANTHERS RIGHT BACK ON AND
DUCLAIR HERS HERE IN THE FIRST
SHORTHANDED HAS BEEN TERRIFIC.O
FIRST PART OF THE AND CALIFORNI
NATIVE PLAYING FOR
THEY ARE
HUBERDEAU TO SET THREE.  I'M SU
POINT SHOT SAVED.S
KINGS AND POINTS A SYSTEM POWER-
PLAY GOALS.
ON THE MOVEBREAK RIGHT
THERE.
THEY HAD TWO PLAYERS
SURROUNDING DUSTIN B
HORNQVIST, THERE'S A GOOD
SCORING CHANCE.
THAT'S WHAT THE PANTHERS ARE  Y
>> SHOOTING IS
HE HITS THE BOARDS.
>> ALL THAT PRESSURE BY
IT'S ALL OVER.
TREVOR MORE RISKS IT.
>>